I want to thank every all of our
speakers that are up here for
participating today I think it made a
really nice integrative panel of talks I
think that we all learned so much from
very different perspectives so if we can
just take a moment I want to just thank
them for coming and joining us and we
have a couple questions I mean that were
directed to specific people so I'm going
to start with those this one was for
Stacy there was a question about about
how you were able to handle going to
school and getting a job and getting
married and and the things that you did
accomplish in your life in the the
context of the experience of BPD your
anxieties and your insecurities did you
feel that there was something that
pulled you through doing all that was so
strong and I was so I was such an alien
in that world that I knew that I there
was no place for me there I had to get
out and find where there was a place and
you know the one thing that more than
any other has saved me in life is books
literature and I wanted to go to the
place where there were the maximum
number of books and writers and it was
always my goal to get to New York you
know when I was a little kid that was
watching a little kid teenager and I was
watching Woody Allen movies and going I
just want to get to the place where they
have apartments full of books
it was it was literature was books I
just had to get away from the from the
Jesus and to where the books were like
it's that simple you know it wasn't easy
it was just that there was I didn't fit
there was no place for me there so I had
to go find the place where
fit okay thank you dr. Swenson there's a
question about how do that peer-to-peer
DBT skills training models work do you
need to have a peer Center or or can you
have other modalities in which they're
implemented and are the facilitators
trained graduates of skills training
groups or is it can you learn some other
way I've known a number of different I
guess groups or situations where people
who've been through DBT skills have been
grouped together and started to form
peer to peer support groups peer to peer
teaching skills reviewing skills
sometimes it's because there's just not
enough resources in the community to
keep it going with professionals
sometimes people just would prefer to
try it without professionals there's one
that that's worked really well for about
12 or 13 years where I am in Western
Massachusetts where we sort of developed
a model where there's a nurse who is DBT
skilled person and very enthusiastic
about them and she teams up with a team
of people from the department mental
health patients in our area that have
been through DBT and if they want to
after they've been through at least a
year they can connect with her and then
join up and become a co-teacher with her
and then they go teach the skills to
other populations other situations they
go to hospitals they go to club houses
they go to residential settings and they
teach an eight or nine
weak skills a package with a co-teaching
between a professional and a peer and it
worked really well and so she has a
whole team that she considers the peer
teaching consultation team and and they
work together so over the years she's
gone through doing that with maybe 20
different people and what's been amazing
is to see that it's the next step in
recovery for the ones who do the
teaching and you can see that it's
valuable for the ones that receive the
teaching that really the ones who have
obviously benefit is the ones who do the
teaching they sometimes are still going
in and out of a hospital now and then
but that doesn't disqualify them they
just have to show up and they get ready
and they teach part of it and she
teaches part of it and then week by week
or month by month she gets over more to
the each of them and she takes a
background role and three of those
people have now gotten paying jobs in
our area as skills teachers so it's been
a really successful that's just one
model I think there's probably other
ways to do it so that it sounds from one
of the questions is asking something I'm
gonna kind of blend a couple of them
together but it sounds like each of you
mentioned a little bit about how
therapist factors play a role in health
acacia s-- the therapy is that's being
implemented I think it even started off
this morning with you have to like the
therapy if I'm remembering what she said
correctly Suzanne that that you have to
like the therapy you're doing in order
to be efficacious with your patients so
there are a couple questions about that
about wondering how much do you each
think that the therapist factors what
qualities in the therapists do you think
are facilitating each form of treatment
what do you think therapists need to
have in order to successfully implement
that form of treatment anyone
could I say that there's there's a
tremendous amount of evidence for this
not just in borderline personalities or
but across the field so there's a guy
named womp old he took huge datasets and
instead of nesting them by cognitive
behavioral or psychodynamic or this or
that he nested them by therapist and it
becomes very clear that the therapists
effect is more powerful than the
cognitive behavioral or psychodynamic or
whatever and maybe the interaction is
very powerful but clearly there are
therapists effects there's no doubt
about it
now the next question which I'm going to
leave for my learning colleagues is so
what are the best therapists what I can
say about all the treatments because
I've participated in a number of
different treatments for BPD is that I
think number one it takes openness and a
balance of clarity with humility you
have to be very clear about what you're
doing why you're doing it whether or not
it's working and have enough openness
and humility humility to know when it's
not working you know because I think
that with the rise of evidence-based
treatments people do become more rigid
about what they do and even before of
evidence-based treatments in
psychoanalysis there was a lot of
rigidity at times and there's a reason
for it it's not like just a kind of
thing to be devalue but in the face of
some painful realities about people's
lives you have to brace yourself with
something and working with these
patients even though it's really
rewarding and successful at times it's
very intense and it creates burnout
whether it's in the family or in the
therapist and I think it's something
that you have to be able to face and
recognize and have some radical
septon silver and be able to kind of
regulate yourself around and mentalize
around and understand the relationship
around so I think there's something to
be learned from all these treatments and
you know I think that that is really
what matters more than you know a
specific thing but what I what I can say
about mentalization based treatment is
that people who don't like not knowing
aren't going to be good at it and like
if you can't say I don't know or I made
a mistake or it might have caused you a
problem you're not going to be a good I
think
therapist with these patients in general
but I think in mentalizing treatment you
really have to start with being able to
say that I would just go pick up right
there
I was thinking also the support you said
humility
I thought persistence is one humility is
one the qualities but another thing
that's hard to capture I think is that a
therapist has to be alive and I think
what brings you alive as a therapist is
that you do things that actually fit you
that actually work for you so that when
you say you have to be comfortable with
not knowing now people who aren't that
comfortable with not knowing might be
fabulous therapists when they're doing
something else so but if you do
metallization if you're not comfortable
not knowing you're in the wrong model I
mean and you have to sort of bridge that
gap somehow but I find you know figuring
out what works and it's different for
different patients so it's very complex
because what I do for some patients I do
different things than for other patients
I have to find what works for me which
then also works for them and works for
both of us
and you want other qualities I think
that if you want your therapist your
patient to be committed to changing and
care about changing
if you don't deeply care about it it
won't happen
it'll just be you can't just deliver one
of these models as if it's a technique I
think you have to feel like I'm doing
this because the world depends on it
because this patient depends on this
family depends on it this because this
is going to work and I'll change gears
if I need to and I think it's modeled by
all of the best teachers in every model
I think that just on the other hand in
terms of as we have more evidence-based
practices and rigidity in some ways on
the other hand I think they've allowed
us to be more flexible and I think your
word humility is so perfect because one
of the things that I appreciate is that
ability to say you know what I'm doing
how I'm working with you may not be
working and here's all these other
things that can help and if I don't know
how to do it can I get you to the right
person so I think this other issue of
being curious being generous with and
with the idea that there are more than
one way to help you and and I've also
been very big with my patients on this
kind of whole notion of informed consent
here's here's the model I'm using I like
doing this model I've helped people with
it it may not work for you here's these
other models here's what we know about
them here's who do them and letting you
know people are grown-ups like I'm gonna
except for the kids but you know I mean
they can pick and I think this is why
also access to multiple at multiple
treatments is crucial from a public
health perspective so I just want to say
one thing just to add to what you just
said is that I think that like with
families in the family guidelines you
have to let yourself be hurt you know
that is an important part of the
humility part is that you know to be
able to have an open dialogue I think
that when somebody's in like whether you
call it a motion mind or like
effectively focused rather than
cognitively focused I think it's very
tempting for a therapist or a family
member to get incredibly rational and
authoritative and I think that sometimes
contributes to that rigidity but it's
like an adaptation just like the
symptoms of BPD and just being aware and
mentalizing what you're doing what
you're doing it I think is like a
capacity that is going to help era pused
of any modality as well
as the patient if I may
yeah the single biggest thing that
helped me when I was going through both
DBT and with the therapist that I talked
about dr. Nichols was when they were
willing to share something about
themselves with me that's a huge thing
and the fact that Steve Nichols gave me
a book of his off his shelf and let me
keep it it was an object that I had of
his and I could touch it and I remember
that when my DBT therapist one day
finally told me something about herself
she told me her cat's name her cat's
name was Pandora I'll remember it for
the rest of my life and the fact that
she let me see that she was a human
being and not just someone who knew a
lot more than I did and was going to
teach me how to function in the world
was enormous for me it's true Pandora
the cat Eloise Raymond Brown thank you
in dialect behavior therapy one of the
assumptions we make about therapy is
that it is a real relationship and just
like you talked about real relationship
in the moment I think all good therapies
know you mentioned real relationships
it's not like a pretend relationship to
represent relationships I mean and and
and I so I think that for me I think
this whole notion of appreciating that
and not being afraid to if your limits
are to disclose things you disclose them
do you know different therapists have
different things they're willing to
disclose but for God's sake I mean we're
just human sitting in a room and
hopefully one of us in this moment is
more ordered than the other and are
helping pull the other one there was a
way of saying I'm not afraid of you
you're not you don't have this incurable
thing that's so scary that I'm afraid
that if I tell you anything about me
you'll Spock me and I didn't I think I
hear there's a theme that that the
relationship is key whether it's how
we're thinking about the relationships
the relationship with the therapist how
the therapist relates to the therapy
it's all about relationships in some way
so to say yes surprise there transy
sensitive next to someone they're gonna
get something and we've had different
parents go to the same therapist one it
was revelatory changed life the other
was didn't work at all so the fit and
this may be an X Factor they're the same
way the eyes of my guys but the X Factor
that sensitivity I just want to mention
about HIPAA because a lot of our family
members don't get told anything and it's
very frustrating because if they're in a
situation where their loved one is not
going to sign the HIPAA form they don't
get any information so they actually
asked us to ask clinicians to include
the family in some way and to let them
tell what they see is going on in the
home because they don't often get that
other side it's very good point thank
you we have a lot of questions as you
can see I'm holding them in my hand and
they're all pretty much asking the same
thing and it's it's a cross therapeutic
approaches so I'm going to again put
this to the whole panel there are a lot
of questions about how do you find
someone who's well trained or certified
or knows how to do this therapy how do
you tell that DBT provider is going to
be a good DBT provider versus a
not-so-good one how do you know when if
they're certified what kind of education
do they need to have to make sure that
they're good treatment
tonight I'd anticipate this a little
slightly more complex question to answer
than that but it does the people on the
panel have any recommendations and for
people looking for good treatment
providers I can speak to what I can't
speak obviously to mentalization and
transference focus but I can certainly
speak to the state of the state in terms
of dialectical behavior therapy I've
been working with Marsha on
certification of clinicians and we are
about to go ahead and launch the Linehan
border certification certification
program so that's going online hopefully
was supposed to go on May 1st but if any
of you who've ever worked with Marsha
before June 1st so but I think this is
an important issue because you know
you're working with from again a public
health perspective you're working with a
common severe mental illness in the
terms of its cost of suffering on
individuals and families and you know
it's just like schizophrenia it's about
2% of the population it's quite a bit of
people are affected by it and these
treatments that we've discussed are not
as low as pointed out they they may have
some very basic if you step back and
understand the core of the theories
behind them and the way you're operating
but they're not simple to do and and so
our patients do suffer from people
hanging up shingles saying they know how
to do things and I know that's why in
dialectal behavior therapy anyways it's
become very important that consumers
family members know whether this person
has some chance of fidelity in the model
so that's why we've been been doing that
the other thing that we you do short of
that is and I know Charlie did this way
back even in Massachusetts with what
come at least know what components
they're doing in Minnesota we did we do
we are the only we we had a legislative
mandate that our ma has to pay
differentially for DBT so we pay quite a
bit more for individual therapy and
skills groups so that it covers the cost
of consultation team and phone calls
between sessions
and so we because certification wasn't
available at this national way at the
time we had to develop testing teams
based on their programmatic so there are
ways I'm sure with your treatments as
well that you can educate parents and
family members and patients about what
to look for I'll just say something
about this I think that you know DBT is
replete with a lot of technical kind of
aspects and skills that I think are
really ripe for doing certification and
adherence and I think it's important
that they do that and the kind of
research framework they do but I think
that there's an argument that there's
another side to it is that adherence is
in everything an outcome is important to
and given this literature on functional
problems even when people symptomatic
reliever MIT I think clinicians of any
brand need to really think about is this
treatment helping this person reach
their goal I think that's the gold
standard of whether or not a treatment
works is if this person can have a
meaningful life and that matter is far
more than what the technique is and the
technical implications so you know what
I would say about MBT is we are in a
process of just trying to proliferate it
before we can kind of do this more
refined thing about it but I do think
that all the treatments really do need
to focus on function as a primary
outcome of whether or not it's working
and you can go online
you can contact us and we will try to
help you find somebody in your area the
problem is it's a very sad thing we get
all kinds of requests from all over
Alaska Hawaii you know and places we
don't know and so one of the major
problems is that who's been trained in
specialized treatments but just who and
a local community can help at all all
right even willing yeah but to
oversimplify when somebody asks me if
they live in the Boston area
I tell them to call Louis okay in other
words anybody I know in a medical center
that has some academic interest in and
savvy about the disorder I tell them
that some but there's many places where
that's not true and that's where it
becomes extremely difficult
I actually I get this question a lot I
get readers writing and saying how you
know I where do I go where do I look and
who do I turn to and who's doing this in
my area and I try to sort of keep a list
to give to people over the people that I
know who are doing DBT and obviously
that's all I can speak to because that's
that's what I did so I'm really happy
that I have the opportunity to learn
who's offering other kinds of treatment
but I always tell people but as far as
DB T goes to try to find someone who's
doing actual strict by-the-book Linehan
DBT because I know that I hear people
say that they have gone to therapists
who are doing some DD T you know they
would teach them some skills here and
there but for me it was very much about
memorization and practice and going to
skills training group and having
homework and having to come back with
your diary card and with your homework
done and say I did this stuff in this
step in this stuff because when you're
dealing with that kind of emotional
dysregulation you have to depend on
memmer's a
I think - it's to a certain degree if
you're just you know in colossal
emotional overwhelm and you are trying
to sort of use these skills that
somebody kind of taught you it like it
doesn't work you really have to like I
love the acronyms bless Marsha and her
acronyms because I can go down and be
like describe Express a circuit like
that I needed that and I still do it
yeah thank you well I'm gonna put out
one more question that I think might
take a a looking forward stance maybe as
we think about the next 10 years what we
might be talking about 10 years from now
there has been a theme in the talks
today and this person is talking about
how social functioning and functional
impairment and functional recovery is
certainly a theme across I'm gonna focus
and and the person says you know dr.
Clark and said if vocational impairment
is the main reason that BPD patients
fail to attain or maintain symptomatic
and social functioning how do you think
that we might as treaters work to best
target this problem are there certain
work environments are there other
certain factors that we should be
looking for to to move forward and
improve the overall social functioning
work functioning and other impairment
that remains for patients I'll take a
crack at it from especially I guess well
from any point of view I'll go back to
my comment that what changes is what you
target and I think that we've since at
least since Linehan began the
development of her treatment what's been
targeted relentlessly and in research
has been the problematic behaviors and
the high-risk and the getting a
commitment from somebody and getting
people on board and now there's some
degree of targeting of post-traumatic
stress disorder anxiety disorders there
had been very little targeting of
vocational success in DBT
seeder Kunz actually who has presented
in these meetings before I did a project
in New Mexico DBT for as an adjunct to
vocational rehabilitation that was quite
successful and I and Kate come to our in
Seattle has tried to target getting
people out of the system and I think as
soon as you turn you're you know these
are great treatment models and they have
flexibility if you really have somebody
serious start asking the question and
looking at the outcomes and get an
outcome oriented answer to how do we get
people more successfully working and
having intimate relationships that are
more successful I don't know what will
come of it I mean but I think we could
have a lot of anecdotal answers but I
think the big answer is when's the field
going to start actually taking that
research seriously at least in DBT I
don't think we're there yet and just to
add I mean if you look step back and
look at the field of behavioral health
in all other particularly if you look at
the severe mental illnesses and you look
at Samsa had started working on trying
to roll out toolkits for teams working
as fairly mentally ill individuals not
with those with borderline personality
disorder in the 2000s but you know this
issue of people getting to work and
working at real jobs just because your
schizophrenia it doesn't mean you should
go sit in a workshop and stick widgets'
and an envelope and I know in my in
again because I work in this Republic
health setting in which my big job is to
keep people get them out of the system
and keep them from going into hospitals
you know this issue of targeting your
life needs things in it that are
meaningful in that sense of mastery is
huge or even like this morning we're
talking about sex remember yeah yeah you
know but you know I mean honest to god I
think Charlie's right and even like what
Lois is talking about this idea of while
the field needs to pay attention to
research and it we as individual
clinicians need to have our eyes like a
laser beam on what is going to make your
life functional and so I'm in a setting
where I can follow someone over a number
of years and each each thing that we do
is
as a clinician I can be responsible to
asking you what's gonna make your life
better and target it but I agree with
Charlie we need to study and we need to
make it more obvious to people could I
add Charlie's point I think it's very
clear that if you don't focus on
something it probably won't change
absolutely and so I think the fields now
faced with a at what point in the
treatment can you focus on such things
this work and then then be how do you do
that and what are the steps then I think
that within the next five years I think
the field will be at the point of doing
that
what we're trying to do I think is a lot
like what Lois and John Gunnarsson do
because I was talking to John about this
this week we're building it into the
treatment contract so right at the
beginning we're negotiating with people
not not demanding but we're negotiating
with people how in this treatment are
you going to get back to work volunteer
partial whatever and by the way I'll add
to that and in this job market it's not
so easy for anybody to get a job but for
us it isn't just getting a job it's part
of identity so what is your identity
I don't know about you but I had to find
a lot of myself but why I do and my work
and what it means to me and so it's
trying to gear people along that path
that that has a meaningful connection to
other people in many ways yeah I'll just
add to that just as you alluded to in
general psychiatric management work is
emphasized over love because the core
problem is interpersonal
hypersensitivity if you have
interpersonal hypersensitivity and you
have this identity just clarity of no
direction no structure your likelihood
of having disorganisation your
relationships is high whether it BPD or
not that's why in college as luck
explains college you know your classes
are like Tuesday and Friday or you know
it's not like really kind of regimented
and so I think that to emphasize for BPD
patients we're actually very
heavy-handed in the Gundersen program
which is like a intensive program but we
say you got to stay out of a
relationship until you can sort yourself
out because it's too stressful yeah get
a job so you can regulate yourself I use
my job to regulate myself and when I
don't have work I get dysregulated
sometimes but you know that you really
have to help someone build a life around
which they can kind of manage their
sensitivities so I I'm gonna add one
comment myself if that's all right with
the panel I think that that what we've
you guys have all just been saying was
that we know where the research needs to
be done we know what needs to still be
focused on and and the research just
needs to be implemented and I think it
started out as a joke kind of today
about Germany has all the money and is
throwing it at BPD which is in fact true
there are other countries that are
putting a lot of money and resources
right now towards studying the
phenomenology of BPD and understanding
the underlying neural circuitry and
neural endocrine responses and and
that's something that we that everyone
here in this auditorium right now has
has the potential of having an impact on
we this is you know BPD Awareness Month
and it's also I believe the Mental
Health Awareness Month
and this is a perfect opportunity I am
gonna make a plug right now this is a
perfect opportunity for everyone here
that's invested in this area of
diagnosis and potentially the research
to contact their representatives and let
them know that you would like to see
your tax dollars put towards this
research you know these decisions are
made at the National Institute of Health
the National Institute of Health in the
u.s. is predominantly what funds the
research were talking about today and
that was displayed today in some cases
we're lucky that we don't have to rely
on that but but that is and so I think
as as attendees of this conference we
can think about that and how what what
role our voice could have and helping
direct research for the next ten
simply by calling someone and letting
know we think this is important so we
are out of time
but I want to thank the panel again you
guys have been wonderful and we're very